these squares were emptied of protesters
months ago
a battle for change won by the political
establishment
now the movement for a new lebanon that
began in late 2019
has shifted its focus from the street to
the ballot box
different coalitions born from the
uprising are contesting the upcoming
elections many of the candidates are
young and optimistic but they know
political change won't be easy
we are a country that suffered for 30
years from the corruption and all kind
of militia we need we know that we need
time to change we want to go into the
parliament start the change from inside
they're up against a sectarian-based
system of power sharing and leaders who
are more powerful than the state
politicians largely blamed for the
country's economic collapse
these elections although from the
outside are democratic they're actually
run by the regime itself and the regime
has proven to use different fraudulent
tools to secure its win so from
clientelism to violence to repression
intimidation and even manipulating
vote counting which we saw in the 2018
elections
but those in power still have supporters
and they have been accused of using
violence in this incident the opposition
was prevented from launching its
campaign in the electoral stronghold of
the muslim shia groups hezbollah and
amal
we accuse the forces in charge of this
region of being behind this attack they
are known to prevent any opposition
activity
in lebanon sectarian and political
divisions are deep and the opposition
too was unable to unite to contest the
elections this benefited the political
leadership which also relies on an
electoral law that entrenches sectarian
politics
for those wanting change this battle is
about building a strong civil and
functioning state but they are seen as
politically immature and criticized for
lacking organization and failing to
appeal to the masses
in the last election those campaigning
for a civil society in lebanon known as
the change forces won one seat in the
128-member parliament this time they're
expecting to gain a few more but not
enough to change the system but for them
the election is a necessary battle in a
long war
senator al-jazeera beirut